[Music]
hello everyone
in the previous video we had started our
discussion on
buckling and we had arrived at this uh
rather complicated looking set of
governing equations and boundary
conditions
and at the end of the video i had uh
mentioned
uh how it may be possible to
reduce uh this uh this equation somewhat
let's do that so uh
first of all the first key thing to note
here is that uh
suppose we consider a rod
like this okay so
a draw or a beam or a column up
like this and uh let's say that
this end is free and this end is clamped
so this is just an illustrative case
and we have this kind of
load okay so this is very much
a specific example of the general
situation that we have been dealing with
here
uh you can have transverse direction or
lateral loads also present here but i'm
just considering a very simple case
now you may note that i have not written
any
force in this direction but if you draw
the if you cut this out and
draw the free body diagram of this you
will have the emergence of this reaction
force so it is very much
like a special case of the general
situation we were considering in the
previous video
now in this situation you see that if we
have to consider buckling
then we have to note that uh the us
variable
at this end at x equal to l if the
total length of this beam or rod is
capital l
then the u s variable that is not
specified here
okay and the same situation can be so
if you have a
a hinged end here so instead of this
kind of a free end completely
suppose you have something like this
that
this end is hinged in this fashion
it is hinged like this and
these are these are placed between
rollers or on rollers
okay so this this is this this end is
hinged at this point and
this kind of a setup it allows it to
move in this horizontal direction uh
we can also have another situation where
perhaps the rod is
is
is clamped here so to speak it is
clamped here
but this end where it is clamped
uh that itself so maybe it is some kind
of a platform
and that platform itself is free to
uh maybe rule like this
this is not the greatest of diagrams
engineering diagrams but
uh you you know i hope you get my spirit
now what i'm trying to get here is that
the most important thing to note
and of course you'll have the load p
also here
so what i'm trying to get uh at here
is that the us variable that
has to be such that it is not specified
okay
so coming to this thing coming to this
uh usa specified thing so we have at x
equal to zero and x
equal to l either this or this
so what we are going to say is that
as a first step towards the
simplification of a set of governing
equations and boundary conditions we are
going to say that at x equal to l
u s is actually not specified
okay us is not specified and if us is
not specified
therefore it must immediately follow
that from this either or statement
if one of them is not true then the
other must be true
okay so at x equal to l it must be true
that e a times this curly bracket with
whatever present inside it
must be equal to minus p okay
so this is at x equal to l please note
that
now things get very interesting here you
just take a look
at this governing differential equation
[Music]
okay
note that we have d d x
e a curly bracket okay so this
d d x is over the entire thing that is
equal to zero
and this equation mind you is not true
at x equal to 0 or it
at x equal to l rather over the entire
domain so this is true
over this entire domain
which means that because this is d dx
equal to 0 this month
means that e a times the curly bracket
of that that is
equal to constant and this thing is true
for all values of x lying between 0 and
l included
okay now you see the interesting
situation on the one hand we have at x
equal to l e a curly bracket is equal to
minus b but on the other hand we are
saying or we are obtaining from the
governing equation
that ea curly bracket is equal to
constant over the whole domain
now if it is a constant over the whole
domain and at any one point within
on that domain which is at x equal to l
we are saying we are finding that ea
has a particular value which is minus p
then it must be true
and it must must be true then that all
over the domain elsewhere also
it has to be that same exact constant
value okay
so you think about it for a second it
will strike you
okay so the the conclusion from this
and this is that
ea
the ea curly bracket must be equal to
minus p
all throughout the domain okay let me
write that better
it must follow that e a
curly bracket must be equal to minus p
for all values of x lying between zero
and l
okay okay so if that is true
ea curly bracket is equal to minus p all
throughout
uh x then you see in the second
governing equation we also have this
presence of this ea curly bracket so
everything is kind of coming together so
this equation also is true for all
values of x lying between 0 and l
and if that is so we already have found
that e curly bracket is equal to minus p
all that have to do here is come back
here and substitute e a curly bracket is
equal to minus b
okay so let me uh let me copy this
equation
and go to the next slide
the second governing equation that is
going to give me
minus ddx
ea curly bracket that is replaced by
minus p
dw dx
all right and if
these is a constant so what we can do is
we can rewrite this entire thing as e
[Music]
i
all right so you see
uh as in the process
of finding our governing differential
equation uh
for the for the buckling
we have arrived at a fourth order
equation where
just like our normal bending case we
have the presence of this term this e i
d 4 w d x
4 if you compare with the previous
theory but in addition we have this
extra term this p d squared w d x
squared which was not present earlier
okay so without this term this is
exactly like what we had
obtained earlier in our previous videos
but
this is the extra thing that is
occurring okay
so now
one may argue that okay we have done all
of this thing but it seems like a linear
equation doesn't it
i mean it is a linear differential
equation like a so
it's a it's a fourth order differential
equation but it is a linear equation
okay but it does include within it
the non-linear ingredient okay which is
why it will be able to
capture buckling now uh let us not just
stop here
uh we should be very happy that we have
managed to
simplify our governing equations because
please note that
captured within this one equation is the
information
from the first of the governing
differential equation okay you see what
is
what has happened is that in the process
of finding that one governing equation
we have utilized the information from
this because we have used this we have
already
integrated this out to obtain this and
that we have utilized
uh and to obtain this information which
this information in turn we have
replaced substituted here
so whatever we have obtained at the end
that one governing differential equation
it encapsulates within it
the information from the other governing
equation also so so this
uh this pair of governing equations
which were obtained in the previous
video
that is perfectly equivalent to the one
equation which we have just now
obtained which is this equation okay so
this is
this is rather important very very
important
we mark it out
but what about the boundary conditions
so so let's take a quick look there
so in the boundary conditions we have
again already utilized this one
okay so we don't we don't have to
consider it we have already utilized
this information
the governing equation that we have is
purely in terms
of the w so
wherever uh now we have the w present so
basically these two sets uh we are going
to utilize that
let me just copy it out
but here also a little simplification
will be possible
boundary conditions
at x equal to zero
and x equal to l we have the following
but you please note that this e a curly
bracket is nothing but minus p
so what we can do is we can just replace
this thing
by this minus t
right so that's all there is to it
so uh so we'll see
uh how we can use these uh these general
boundary conditions
to uh to to certain specific uh
cases okay so the problems that can be
uh possible from uh from this part
of the theory uh will be based on
various kinds of applications
of these boundary conditions and the
solution of this governing differential
uh equation all right so on that note
i'll end this video and in the next one
uh
i'll i'll discuss the
one example all right thank you very
much